En videos anteriores hemos usado modelos de área
para visualizar la multiplicación de expresiones,
por ejemplo, multiplicar (x + 7) (x + 3). En
esos videos vimos que para encontrar el área de
un rectángulo podemos dividir sus longitudes.
En este ejemplo, una parte de este lado tiene
longitud x y el resto longitud 7, esto es
7, la longitud total de este lado es x + 7;
y en este lado la longitud es x + 3. Los
modelos de área nos ayudan a visualizar
por qué multiplicamos los diferentes términos
o cómo multiplicamos los diferentes términos,
porque si estamos buscando el área total va a ser
x + 7, (x + 7) (x + 3), por x + 3, y luego por
supuesto podemos dividir esto en sub rectángulos.
Este rectángulo, que en realidad es un cuadrado,
va a tener un área de x², este de aquí tendrá un
área de 7x, 7 por x; este de aquí tendrá un área
de 3x, y luego este de aquí tendrá una área
de 3 por 7 o 21. Y así podemos darnos cuenta
de que el producto final va a ser x² + 7x + 3x
+ 21, esa será el área de todo el rectángulo.
Por supuesto podríamos sumar 7x y 3x para obtener
10x, pero algunos de ustedes podrían preguntarse:
"Bueno, todo esto está muy bien. Cuando tengo
+ 7 y + 3 puedo pensar en longitudes positivas,
puedo pensar en áreas positivas, pero ¿y si no
fuera así? ¿Qué pasaría si estuviéramos tratando
con números negativos en lugar de estos?" Por
ejemplo, si ahora intentáramos hacer lo mismo,
podríamos decir: "Está bien, esta longitud
superior que tenemos aquí es x - 7";
intentémoslo y llamemos a esta longitud de aquí
arriba - 7, entonces tenemos una longitud de - 7,
y no estamos necesariamente acostumbrados a pensar
en longitudes negativas. Vamos a continuar. Y
luego esta altura sería x - 3, podríamos escribir
una x para esta parte de la altura y para esta
parte podríamos poner - 3, entonces veamos: si
continuamos con lo que hicimos la última vez, el
área aquí sería x², el área aquí sería - 7 por x,
entonces eso sería -7x, esta área verde sería -3x,
entonces esta área naranja sería -3 por -7 que es
21 positivo, y luego diríamos que todo el producto
es x² - 7x - 3x + 21. Por supuesto podemos sumar
estos dos para obtener -10x. ¿Pero esto tiene
sentido? Bueno, una forma de pensar en esto es
que un área negativa es un área que quitarías
del área total, de modo que si x resulta ser
un número positivo aquí entonces esta área
rosa sería negativa, y así la quitaríamos del área
total. Y eso es exactamente lo que está sucediendo
en esta expresión, y vale la pena mencionar
que incluso antes, cuando este no era un -7,
cuando era 7 positivo, y esto era 7x positivo,
era completamente posible que x fuera negativa,
en cuyo caso habría tenido un área negativa de
todos modos. Pero para apreciar que todo esto
funciona incluso con números negativos, haré el
ejemplo si x fuera igual a 10, eso nos ayudará a
dar sentido a las cosas. Así que si x fuera igual
a 10, obtendríamos un modelo de área como este:
tenemos 10 - 7, así que pondré menos 7 justo
aquí, multiplicado por 10 - 3. Ahora ¿puedes
darte cuenta a qué va a ser igual esto? 10 - 7
es 3, 10 - 3 es 7. Entonces todo esto debería
sumar 21 positivo, asegurémonos de que esto
ocurra realmente. Entonces, esta área azul
es igual a 10 por 10 que es 100; esta área
rosa ahora es 10 por - 7, de modo que es -70,
así que lo vamos a quitar del área total; esta
área verde es - 3 por 10 que es igual a - 30,
y luego - 3 por - 7, esta área naranja es 21
positivo. ¿Todo esto funciona? Veamos, si tomamos
esta área positiva: 100 - 70 - 30 + 21, 100 - 70
= 30 - 30 es 0, y luego sólo nos quedan 21, que es
exactamente lo que esperamos. Podríamos mover
esta área rosa sobre el área azul y restarla,
y luego podríamos tomar esta área verde, ponerla
vertical y restarla del resto del área azul,
y todo lo que nos quedaría sería esta área
naranja. Espero que esto te ayude a apreciar que
los modelos de área para multiplicar expresiones
también funcionan si los términos son negativos.
Como recordatorio, las x de aquí también
podrían haber sido negativas en un principio.